the work of Stella archeology really
goes to the heart of the we are Stardust
when we are children of the stars
statement you've probably heard it all
but what does it actually mean we are
mostly made all humans and all life
forms that we know of made mostly of
carbon and a bunch of other elements but
in much lesser quantities where does
this carbon come from well you could say
it comes from the earth and yes that is
true but how did it get into the earth
right and so that is where astronomy
comes in because there are multiple
so-called nucleosynthesis processes that
create elements heavy elements they fuse
lighter ones into heavier ones starting
with hydrogen four hydrogen atoms come
together and fuse into a helium atom and
if you throw helium three helium atoms
together you get a carbon nucleus and
this is how carbon is created and we are
establishing how much carbon was created
at various times in the universe and
through which processes and through
which in which types of stars and in
what evolutionary phases of the star
system happens and so this is how we can
piece together the chemical evolution of
the universe that was really the the
basis for any biological evolution to
take place on earth and I find it really
exciting to to go back and really look
at the at the constituents of life
separately and we have studied not just
carbon but also nitrogen and phosphorus
and sulfur and oxygen and iron and all
the different elements through our work
and stellar archaeology and actually if
you come to think about it the body is
not just made of carbon but also a lot
of water and there is hydrogen and
oxygen in the water and well we know
oxygen also comes from the stars you add
another helium nucleus to a carbon
nucleus and you get an oxygen nucleus
but the water the the hydrogen that's
just protons they were all formed in the
Big Bang so we actually carry about 10%
of our body weight in in us that that is
Big Bang material the protons were all
recycled numerous times throughout the
stars but the actual protons were made
in the hot Big Bang when all the support
ohmic particles actually came together
and foreign protons and neutrons and so
that we are we are not just children of
the stars actually we are also children
off of the Big Bang and I think it's
really nice once in a while to to
reflect on that and and really realize
how much we are actually connected to
the cosmos